todo
[Música]
hola hoy en science click la dualidad
onda corpúsculo
a simple vista pareciera que pudiéramos
distinguir dos tipos de objetos en el
universo por un lado algunos objetos se
comportan como puntos con una posición
bien definida y que pueden moverse en el
tiempo este es el caso de una manzana un
coche o un planeta
por otro lado también podemos encontrar
mecanismos de propagación los cuales no
tienen una posición en si se trata de
las ondas como las que se producen en la
superficie del agua
imaginemos un muro con dos rendijas
situamos detrás de este una pantalla
capaz de detectar los objetos que la
alcanza
si lanzamos consecutivamente objetos
puntuales los cuales se comportan como
canicas acabaremos teniendo dos bandas
bien diferenciadas en la pantalla que
corresponden a las dos ranuras por las
que han pasado los objetos
por otro lado si ahora enviamos ondas
como las olas en el agua al propagarse
tras las dos rendijas se superpondrán
al superponerse las olas se sumarán
entre sí para formar una ola más grande
o se anularán mutuamente para formar una
ola más pequeña
la pantalla mostrará entonces una
sucesión de franjas brillantes y oscuras
correspondientes a las crestas y valles
formados por las olas
así se obtienen diferentes resultados
según el tipo de objeto dos bandas
perfectamente delimitadas en el caso de
los objetos puntuales y una sucesión de
franjas de interferencia en el caso de
las ondas como las que se producen en la
superficie del agua
sin embargo si nos interesamos en la
escala cuántica esta distinción entre
corpúsculo y onda parece desaparecer
en el mundo de las partículas una
partícula no tiene una posición bien
definida de hecho cuenta con varias
posibilidades
diferentes posiciones a su disposición
con proporciones que pueden variar
solo en el momento de medir su posición
una de estas posibilidades se realiza
definiendo de forma aleatoria una
posición bien precisa para la partícula
resulta que mientras mayor sea la
proporción de una posición inicialmente
disponible más probable será que al
observar la la partícula se encuentre en
ese lugar concreto
esto nos permite trazar una curva que
corresponde a la probabilidad de
observar la partícula en cada punto del
espacio cuando medimos su posición la
partícula se encontrará de preferencia
en un lugar donde la curva de salta una
posición asociada a una alta
probabilidad en vez de un lugar donde
esa curva sea baja de baja probabilidad
pero esta curva de probabilidad no es
estática con el paso del tiempo
evoluciona de forma muy similar al
movimiento de una ola
[Música]
retomemos nuestro experimento pero con
partículas esta vez e imaginemos que
podemos observarlas sin determinar su
posición
de esta forma la partícula que enviamos
inicialmente no tiene una posición bien
definida por lo tanto su curva de
probabilidad se propagara en el espacio
como si fuera una onda así como las olas
en el agua esta curva pasará por las dos
rendijas al mismo tiempo y se
sobrepondrá entre sí al otro lado del
muro
llegar a la pantalla formando el mismo
patrón que habría formado una ola una
franja alternada de crestas y valles la
finalidad de la pantalla es medir la
posición de la partícula lo que forzará
la determinación de esta misma de forma
muy precisa la partícula se encontrará
en un lugar donde la probabilidad sea
alto es decir en un punto de una cresta
de la curva de probabilidad
entonces se observará un pequeño punto
en la pantalla en el lugar proyectado
por la medida
la partícula adquiere la apariencia de
un pequeño punto lo que podría sugerir
que se ha comportado como una pequeña
canica y por lo tanto que las partículas
son objetos puntuales sin embargo si
seguimos enviando las una a una las
partículas se reunirán en las crestas
porque es ahí donde la probabilidad de
encontrarlas es mayor
terminaremos observando en la pantalla
el mismo patrón que obtuvimos al enviar
las ondas las partículas se han agrupado
todas a la altura de las crestas y por
lo tanto han formado este patrón
conjuntamente
las partículas que componen nuestro
universo no son mi corpúsculos ni ondas
en ocasiones pueden tener las
propiedades propias de los objetos
puntuales y en otras las propiedades
propias de las ondas esta dualidad onda
corpúsculo que reina en el mundo
cuántico se debe a que la partícula
antes de ser observada es descrita por
una curva de probabilidad y que esta
curva de probabilidad se propaga y
evoluciona en el tiempo como una onda
[Música]